i lived with my mom at the time you know
i had food clothes i had a tv in my room
i didn't need to go down with a guy
my mom was already doing that
but now now i live on my own so i think
you know two times a year is an
acceptable amount of times
aladdin relax i really like you i i
really do and i really like you too
i want to do everything with you you
know see the world and laugh together
and sing songs and and do sex
i wouldn't call it doing sex i'm just
i'm worried that if i try to go in i
i might not make it in all the way there
you got you got engaged to ariana grande
yeah i did you know what do you remember
when uh that whole city pretended that
kid was batman because he was like sick
that's what this feels like
this is how they write about colin in
our hometown newspaper the staten island
advance
colin jost tees up it's about three
weeks till election but you could never
tell by colin joe's swing
and here's how they write about me the
best part about this one was his
interaction with colin jokes
because when you're like 15 and your mom
catches you like it's embarrassing but
on some level when she closes the door
like she's proud you know
she's like wow my boy is growing up
you know no because when you're 25 and
your mom catches you masturbating it's
like this should not have happened who
just walks into the kitchen without
knocking
look at the picture they use of you
right
now look at the picture they use of me
why do you think they don't like you
pete if i had to guess it's maybe
something i said in an interview once
that i wished that when hurricane sandy
hit staten island it had finished the
job
brandon you getting a little ticky down
there sorry
[Applause]
um i just needed a way to get out here
so i could talk about what's really on
my mind
which is that you guys are uh hosting
the emmys this year i'm a little sick
about it like
no it's bad enough watching you guys
like strut around this place with all
your accomplishments you know like head
writers
update hosts
harvard
black
well i can see how what you said might
make you more unpopular well it was just
a joke
a serious joke like you know like when
you're joking but you mean it
i don't even feel that way anymore i'd
be just as happy if there were no
hurricane and staten island just fell
into the sea
for secretary of commerce the pick is
wilbur ross i've heard this guy's a
billionaire investor but i'm pretty sure
i've seen him sitting on jeff dunham's
lap
then they got to deputy white house
press secretary sarah huckabee sanders
who's one of those sweet southern girls
that you marry if you're gay
there's an etsy store selling pete
davidson vibrators
yeah
how weird is that you could buy a
vibrator with my face on it for 15
or one without my face for 20.
i don't even get a cut of the sails now
i know how chappelle feels
right
i wrote you an instagram caption babe oh
that was fire all right
a kingly beautiful boy oh
toxic
oh viral oh twin flame rehab barbie oh i
wish i could vape you
hey yo hey yo keep in mind this is
coming from kanye but y'all weird the
reason staten island hates me is because
i represent what they are
you know a mentally ill community
college dropout
who got a game of thrones tattoo before
watching the show
[Applause]
i think i speak for all crazy people
when i say
[Laughter]
aim over here and i will make you very
rich man
we can save each other short long quick
cartwheel up to me
now look i'm totally comfortable being
with a successful woman i think it's
dope i live at her place you know
she pays like 60 grand for rent and all
i have to do is like stock the fridge
well the man doesn't always have to be
the bread winner in a relationship god
damn right kong
he does not yeah cuomo he looks like a
guy that's sleeping with your mom but
stays overnight and eats breakfast with
you in his boxers
and then
and then he asked you how the baseball's
going and you say you don't play
baseball and he goes oh queer
[Music]
you uh feel when you first heard that
rowling said something transphobic uh it
really hurt you know because i have a
close connection to those movies i even
look like dobby the house elf if he
became a tick tock rapper but the only
difference between me and dobby is i'm a
real person and his movies get released
in theaters
this guy is a monster and he should go
to jail forever but if you support the
catholic church isn't that like the same
thing as being an r kelly fan
like no
i don't really see the difference
only like one's music is significantly
better
uh what kanye said after he went off the
air last week was one of the worst like
most awkward things i've ever seen here
and i've seen chevy chase speak to an
intern
i'm like on the left i'm like oh god
and then i'm like i want a career so i
leave
i'm not insane i know i shouldn't be
making fun of how anyone looks
uh
i look like i make vape juice in a
bathtub
i look like a dr seuss character went to
prison
then kanye said that democrats broke up
black families with welfare and that's
slavery is not real
um do you know how wrong about politics
you have to be for like me to notice
big old fat nip seriously
america
look at pete davidson's lips
[Applause]
everybody uses math
[Music]
lisa simpson
bill cosby
mario party
tiny dick
and morgan mindy
no no no no sorry
look at your father boy
look upon your father
i see you man
they were never born
oh sick
i
i am you into the ground uh
pedophilia
and keith um
uh
how would you say that oh queef keith
queef
and i should mention that we did not
know mr queef was inside so when he came
out it was a delightful surprise
we will update you as we learn more
thank you